[Music]
woke up made coffee contemplated number
two looked at porn watch bait car loser
watch since Munro tins cat wrangling
[Music]
with the point again put on Gandalf
costume for no reason and the home rap
song about handling napped ordered
doughnuts so you don't deliver bend it
on Yelp about lack of doughnut delivery
took a picture of my own junk
accidentally send it to Obama
dude watch Breaking Bad napped read
cinemasins
emails read cinemasins comments
[Music]
created premier file for since video
that distracted by hilarious Miley Cyrus
tweet looked a porn again pretended to
work with my wife came home recorded
sins narration to sonic yeah can I get
eight de number two again but the NSA's
profiling system by searching on Google
Daniels in 20 minutes and played Batman
Arkham City awesome I am going to say
[Music]
some things about Jack
this is taking Batman forever to find a
bozo ah found it haha on accident it is
readily apparent I don't know how to get
out of here why is Batman narrating this
about his abilities this is my Jane
come back
Oh - don't